live and direct from Hollywood how do
you find the best taco in Los Angeles
I'm gonna play a little game of taco
Chuck telephone taco telephone taco
telephone so we want to find the best
tacos and what better way to do that
than to go to a taco truck at that taco
vending establishment we are going to
ask them what they think is the best
taco truck and go to that taco truck and
ask them what their favorite taco Chuck
is and then we want to just keep hopping
around until we find absolute finest
taco in the County of Los Angeles and
we're also gonna eat some tacos judging
for ourselves what's the best tacos
how many different kinds of tacos you
have okay we will get one of each let's
test it out and see what we got here
double wrap is what you need your
tortillas on there
it's a lot of cheese on mine now best or
taco el pesto
ah no I can't go that one now why beans
you don't like beans guy doesn't eat
beans he's on a taco adventure Cheers
mmm not bad right cactus Richard good
taco yes we got we got the two beef what
after Freddie massacred this chicken
taco so good that is delish that is like
the sauce is incredible it's whimsical
wimp okay mm-hmm and then I have one
question for you if you aren't eating
tacos here where is your favorite place
to eat tacos in Los Angeles I went to
Hollywood they follow a rheostat goal
that I gave them for location so I
always always eating my pain I don't
have to go to an iron plate this is it I
mean we're starting off in a really
strong foot I don't know if any other
places can tap these but we'll see hey
if there's one thing I've learned about
Los Angeles never underestimate the
valley and that's where we're headed
next what you know make it yeah I make
it you know just getting a little bit
what could happen at the next cycle
place that would make it better I fall
in love with the man in the guy goes I
think that make it I think that would
make the video we're cabeza
BuChE Theresa Theresa penguia and Biddy
yes so good I've never had a taco that
offered like this bread though Chris you
did the trees are right
come on oh yeah cheering Dennis looms at
all times a million
oh my god times a million uneven ones
for anymore oh the seasoning I know
right I mean it's like let me add it oh
yeah tequila communal Rico's tacos gets
an enthusiastic thumbs up hangs better
than cactus so what we're doing is we're
going to different taco vendors
restaurants and trucks we're asking them
where they like to eat tacos and Ellie
let me think about that
he sits out you know and been a nice
thank you
so our next Valley
Oh Terry no I haven't reached the
pinnacle of fullness yet I think after
the next place that might be slowing
down Stephen doesn't look like he agrees
can you talk about birthdays what Oh
oh my god Amy can walked up to Tong Tong
get dirty on that language another I
like fresh the onion is especially like
that's where the difference is it's an
iPhone like those things oh yeah
anything I'll be ever saying that I like
Tong but that was a good tongue tacos
purpose rings oh yeah sweetheart oh man
Wow sweet like it has a sweet a slightly
sweet aspect to it but it's like not
overwhelming the mouth-watering has
started like other talking to keep
getting better and better than she's
working guys taco telephone is working
when you're not eating your own food
where else do you go for the booze tacos
way tacos way serves booze Hey Bruce is
really good to know if any of you ever
had a michelada before yeah none of you
found out that it oh my god we have
three people who are gonna have an
enchilada for the first time your minds
are all gonna be blocked - an impressive
taco adventure Andrew and Freddy are
gonna have their first micheladas right
now well I love beer and I love spices I
love
all my favorite day yeah it's the spot
yes with gelada yeah he does okay I'm
blown that's right
ronita says the crispy ends it just
makes it it's like heaven like pork
flavored popcorn yeah it's the stuff
definitely was hung or hit something
that came from this region I like it a
lot is super tender and like it just
slide on down your throat
at fives all around guys yeah we went to
progressively more awesome taco spots
throughout the day you know I love about
this I love that light every time you go
to a new place you're telling them that
somebody else has amended that place
yeah that's what yeah they're always
thrilled thanks for tuning in to another
episode of
I don't know where this is Paul yet
insert name here okay we'll see you next
time I want to do burgers next can't
Wayne sure pebble down pastrami
sandwiches dumplings oh my god we could
do